a key piece of president biden's agenda
is coming under fire from some fellow
democrats progressive members of the
house say they will not support the
president's infrastructure bill unless
the evenly divided senate passes a
separate three and a half trillion
dollar spending bill the showdown is
expected on monday when the
infrastructure bill is brought up for a
vote christina raffini is at the white
house christina good morning
good morning michelle that's right the
vote on that infrastructure bill that
we've been talking about seems like all
year is supposed to be on monday which
is why the budget committee is in a rare
saturday session trying to hammer out
the details on that larger spending bill
hoping it will also be ready by the
start of the week but democratic debate
and infighting is putting the
president's domestic agenda at risk
mr president do you have any greater
clarity on what moderates want in your
infrastructure deal yeah but i'm
negotiating with them not you guys
president biden is back at the
bargaining table this time with his own
party over the details of a 3.5 trillion
dollar spending plan
now
we're at this stalemate at the moment
and we're going to have to get these two
pieces of legislation passed
progressives say they won't support the
1.2 trillion dollar infrastructure bill
passed with bipartisan support earlier
this summer without the spending plan
expected to include funding for
democratic priorities like climate
change and expanding medicare we have to
deliver on the president's agenda and if
we don't have the reconciliation bill
done the infrastructure bill will not
pass but moderates say the price tag is
too big hit the pause button
let's sit back let's see what happens
and there's another deadline the debt
ceiling and looming government shutdown
we'll we'll keep government open earlier
this week the house passed a measure to
both keep the government funded past
october and raise the debt limit
but republicans say they won't pay off
uncle sam's credit card just so
democrats can run it up again and argue
the funding measure should be its own
bill
i'm not going to increase a debt limit
to re to spend another five trillion
dollars in the next month
now that multi-trillion dollar spending
bill was also initially supposed to
include measures on immigration reform
but the senate parliamentarian ruled it
couldn't be inserted into the
pre-existing bill now this is a
long-time democratic priority that still
remains unaddressed dana
christina thank you